they are the team behind the horror
comedy entitled some guy who kills
people director Jack Perez and
screenwriter Ryan Levin join us in
studio today Jack Perez is a 20-year
veteran of the motion picture and
television industry he graduated with
honors from New York University's
Department of film and television early
on was hired by Sam Raimi ax and
universal studios to direct the pilot
for the popular television series Xena
princess warrior following his work on
Xena Jack Perez has directed nine
feature films that include the big empty
la Cucaracha wild things too and has
written and directed MTV's Monster
Island and mega shark vs giant octopus
Ryan Levin has written on the TV shows
I'm in the band and scrubs he's
consulted on South Park and sold
animated pilots to 20th Century Fox and
Comedy Central Ryan Levin was also
invited to pitch jokes and ideas to
Sacha Baron Cohen AKA bit Borat and ali
g for Cowen's film Bruno he wrote and
directed the short film the fifth Ryan
Levine also wrote and directed the
horror comedy short film toward a fright
after winning financing from boost
mobile's create the next horror villain
contest he is currently working on a
screenplay based on the short film some
guy who kills people is
executive-produced by John Landis and
stars Kevin Corrigan Barry Bostwick and
Karen black awesome film at spotlightz
can Boyd a depressed 34 year old ice
cream parlor employee taunted by town
locals after a recent mental institution
release living at home with his
condescending mother played by Karen
black ken Boyd seeks revenge on those he
deems responsible for his miserable life
adding in a quirky town sheriff played
by Barry Bostwick and a reunion with Ken
Boyd's preteen daughter played by
arielle gate please welcome to the film
courage studio mr. Jack pres and mr.
Ryan Levin welcome gentlemen thank you
very much oh thank you great to have you
here thanks it's an honor to be here
thank you congratulations to you guys on
your accomplishment very cool thank you
very much yeah um you know and and I'm
we're going right into it let's do it
we're going right all right it's right
in no for this interview um you know
we're not gonna hold back we don't want
you guys to hold back and and here's
where where's word on what I wanna start
with you know I can't tell you how many
filmmakers we talked to that tell us
that they don't want to be millionaires
you know they don't need to be
millionaires really all they want is is
to be someone who can make the films
they want to make and earn a living and
you know and Jack you're someone who has
gone out and you've done it what is the
blueprint you know can you tell us
candidly what is it really going to take
for a filmmaker who wants to make a
living making films good question um
well you know I think that that was
probably my philosophy going in was I
don't need to be rich and famous I just
want to be able to to stay alive making
movies I mean even if you reduce that if
you take out the rich and famous part
and say okay maybe that'll make it
easier you're still going to run into
trouble with making the movies that you
want to make that component because if
you're looking for financing if you're
looking for somebody to pay for your
movie they don't necessarily pay for the
movie you want to make they usually pay
for the movie they want to make or what
they deemed to be a good investment and
I found in my life the movies that I'm
really most proud of were those that
weren't actually really seriously or
heavily financed by Hollywood they were
truly independent movies so what I've
done is basically after coming out of
film school I will do anything in the
business as a director or even as an
editor to stay alive doing projects to
you know just to stay alive but always
in the back of my mind having those
handful of movies that will sort of feed
the soul in a way because if you just
keep going making stuff that is not
really your passion you're gonna die you
know spiritually you're going to die and
that's really where I was at at
time that some guy who kills people came
along as successful as mega shark vs
giant octopus was that was not the my
passion pride did that movie you know
just as a last-ditch I had another movie
that fell apart this movie came along I
kind of made it as a gag and it was sort
of an accident that it kind of got so
much attention but when I look at that I
look at that movie it's just kind of a
goof and really not representative of
what I could do as a filmmaker and I
really felt sort of like I'm not making
any money i'm not making the movies i
want to make it's been a long time and
like as fate would have it this is when
ryan's script you know literally i
thought that the moment I was like you
know what the hell with this I've been
doing this 20 years like I'm not happy
interesting this is when the script came
and it really was sort of a life changer
you know for me in that way I mean it
was I think you always have to have your
eye on on what's going to be personally
fulfilling and then do anything else you
can and compartmentalize that you know
and make sure that you know where your
art is and where the just survival bid
is and that's sort of i don't know if
that's an answer but that's sort of the
approach that I've always taken that's
great I want to go back to film school
for a moment as you mentioned that a lot
in your prior interviews and talk about
some of the egos there yeah and you
talked about while in film school you
felt sort of neurotic and you wanted to
make sure that you knew every rule on
set so that you weren't this director
sort of yelling down from an ivory tower
to your gaff right and you know it's
interesting because sometimes we see
things and others that we don't want to
be and that kind of prevents us from
from being that so how did you see those
traits in others at film school and also
for your yourself well I just idea i
just saw that you know a lot of people
posed you know a lot of people like the
idea of being a director because you get
to be the boss and and
everybody look thinks your God and but I
saw very quickly those directors that I
the directors that I really admired it
out of films i mean the filmmakers that
inspired me were ones that were
essentially real masters of the medium
that understood all the aspects of
filmmaking if only to better harness or
explain what you wanted you know to get
your i hate the word vision but they get
your you know the image in your head on
screen if you don't do everything
yourself then you've got to be able to
communicate it so if you understand the
department's then you can do that if you
just stand around like I saw a lot of
people going you know I hunts I five I
have this feat I want this feeling you
know can you give me my feel you know
like basically just asking for this huge
interpretation opposing I thought was
just a you know a bunch of and
I didn't think that was the way to be a
filmmaker so I didn't pretend to be a
total filmmaker I just decided I'm in
film school I'll learn everything about
everything and if I'm you know I
remember I had to do a demonstration
with a light meter like in one class
16-millimeter class i had a like a
psychotic lightning this is how you take
a light meter reading and i remember
being so nervous going up there in front
of the class in my hands were trembling
literally you know and you know i
probably still a sort of lame at getting
a proper reading i probably can but I'm
I ended up shooting movies that it sound
I mixed I got it all down so at least I
knew what was required so that what I
would say this is the next shot I would
knew what I would not only know what how
to do it but how to explain it to know
what was capable and and so I think
that's you should learn them the medium
that you're working in otherwise you're
limiting your own means of expression
you're just hoping somebody guesses what
you're trying to get across so that's
button to answer your earlier question I
think that a lot of people just get into
it because of ego and attitude and and
maybe just wanting to be famous and be
the guy but I've heard stories of major
directors you know sitting around on a
scent reading comic books while
everybody just sort of works until it's
time to call and I could never believe
that I could never understand how
someone could be so removed from the
process
I just think it requires a real razor
sort of sensibility to get it get the
job done unless you just have acres
pounds of money and tons of time which
I've never had so then when you got out
into sort of the quote unquote real
world how did your expectations measure
up and also the of those around you sort
of their hubris of oh I'm going to be
discovered what did you see happen as
far as that film school sort of mindset
then translate into real real world
experience well I think that in general
I think that that the film business will
beat you silly very quickly and so
anybody who isn't like a junkie and I
mean this in the best sense somebody
doesn't anybody doesn't need to make
movies is very quickly it's so hard
unless they get so lucky there's so many
disappointments there's so many things
that don't happen and this is the odds
of the thing you know and i think that
very quickly you see people go yeah i
don't know if i want to be a filming
even if they went to film school and
that's what they wanted to do when they
get you when you get it's like saying i
want to be in a relationship and you
gettin over side ok i swear i'm
sorry you can get you get over so
badly you get somebody like you know I'm
never going to date any I'm never going
to get married I'm never going to do
this again so I think that you have to
be as somebody who can't function
without making a movie just in order to
withstand the blows that come and I saw
a lot of people fall away that's why I
say it's like a it's like a Darwinian
sort of weeding out process and I think
the only people that continued are the
ones that say you know what as bad as it
is I can't seem to be I am not fully
realized as a person unless I'm making
something however long it takes but the
expectations were quickly shattered not
immediately but I thought for example I
was just talking about this the other
night with some friends that if you put
in X number of years of dues paying you
know start at the bottom you know I
started at the bottom I did all kinds of
you know work my way up did a lot of
smaller spots shows the bigger shows I
figured I'd one certain award certain
festivals did all the things that they
told you what's going to happen after
like almost seven or eight years of that
and i would say okay now the gate opens
its like ah you know the girly lets you
they sanction you get standing at a
little metal and now life becomes easier
and you get easier financing and you
make more
and that was not the case at all after
winning film festivals best film and all
that stuff and being having fans around
town it was still very hard to make
movies the ones that I wanted to make
what I did realize was that it works
very much like the mob in the sense that
you the person that gets to make movie
after movie after movie is the film
earlier that's made so much money for a
studio or a financial entity that they
can't not it's almost like being a made
guy but you can't kill this guy the hill
yet this guy made so much money for us
we got to give him another movie whereas
the night a friend of mates to do
picture that made money and even after
it made money he didn't get a job was a
couple years before we go Jeff I was
like how the hell does that happen you
made a movie for the studio it made
money then I had another friend who made
a movie first year made a lot of money
and his movie came very quickly so it
wasn't even enough to be like successful
you have to be like ridiculously
successful for that idea of now you're
in the club so f or anybody else
including myself it's always been like
every time you start a movie whatever it
is it's starting over and you have to be
okay with that process that there's not
going to be this like you can't rest on
there is no resting on something you
know it's sort of like even Ryan and I
are talking about just the other day
what about do doing another movie right
away but even smaller budget just so we
can kind of keep it going and do some
because we had such a great experience
making this movie why don't we just do
something and the idea that it was going
to be tying even smaller got me more
excited because the possibility of
making it became more of an actuality as
opposed to let's go shop this thing
around town and get a deal and blah blah
maybe five years later maybe that's just
again that's sort of like a slow death I
would rather make out make something for
two thousand dollars and then we're
going to make it this year that all of a
sudden like gives me hope you know and i
think a filmmaker lives on that that i'm
actually going to get on set and make
something as opposed to maybe down
yes absolutely great so Ryan what made
you go after the production assistant
job on scrubs back in 2003 and how do
you how do you then go from being a PA
to having a right writing credit for the
same hit TV show I moved I'm originally
from LA when I moved when I was moved to
college in Philadelphia and then to New
York and it took me a while in New York
to figure out what I wanted to do but
after almost five years I started
writing spec TV shows not knowing
anything about the business just writing
them for fun and I quickly realized it
was the most fun I had ever had like was
just writing these episodes of existing
shows and I quickly realized all right
this is the most specific direction I've
had in my career I don't want to leave
New York but it looks like I'm going to
have to if I want to enter into the TV
world so I decided all right I'm going
to pursue a TV writing career and
banette but being from here and not
having anybody in my family in the
business or anything I was you know am I
might as well have been from Wisconsin
or something and you know I there were
no direct ends or anything but before I
left New York I just spoke to it I ended
up speaking to a lot of people through
you know various connections and found
out all right one way to get in is just
to to take that you know that shovel
shovel the job and get your foot in
the door and just be there at all you
know all the time getting people coffee
and everything so I came out here and
found getting a PA job on a TV show was
like the hardest thing in the world
thanks everybody in the city was willing
to do
exactly what yeah I'm like I was gonna
willing to do that for no money turns
out everybody so I just yet I spent
months um you know uh well I guess yeah
I mean I came here a couple months
before what they call TV staffing season
when they would be hiring these pas and
I just blanketed the town with resumes
just saying like I will do anything on
your show for any amount of money and
for every show show they never even
heard of at the time scrubs happen to be
my favorite show and and I sent one in
and found out I knew somebody who knew
somebody got an interview there and got
this PA job which because of our awesome
production coordinator literally
amounted the shoveling and but I
but in talking to pee I was i I was very
careful not to be pushy about my real
aspirations everybody knows nobody's
aspirations are to be a PA everybody's
there for one reason or not another to
be a producer to be a writer director
whatever but I knew well enough to just
kind of hang back and you know do my
time but in talking to some of the
higher level people just who were nice
enough to just chat with me I made my
interest in writing clear in middle of
the year got you know bumped up to
writers PA so all of a sudden instead of
getting coffee for you know actors i was
getting it for the writers which to me
was like a huge promotion because i was
in that i was now at least surrounded by
the people i wanted to you know learn
from and so from there that i went from
writers PA and i was there for three
years total and moved up to writers
assistant which basically put me in the
room with the writers and got me the
chance to to just you know take notes
and and just see how writers room worked
and just
learn from this amazing group of writers
on this you know extremely well-written
well-respected show did that for two
years and in my third year there the
showrunner you know had had asked to see
some of my own writing which I was doing
on the side and was very supportive and
became a fan of mine and offered me the
chance to write an episode unfortunately
I knew from the beginning that on some
show's writers assistance can get bumped
up to full time writers I knew from the
beginning that this particular
showrunner didn't have that policy as a
matter of fact his policy was no rider
assistant will ever become a staff
writer on my show and he had his reasons
for that which I hate but I respect and
so I knew that the the best I could get
out of it would be a script but I you
know at least that would do something
and then from there that opened the door
to getting an agent and and then and
then basically pursuing TV jobs from you
know TV staffing jobs from there on out
so and kudos to you to keep going
because I believe you mentioned in
another interview that when you were
kind of at a crossroads in your life you
kind of said well I don't want to be
that guy at the starbucks with the
macbook like rhino typing it just seems
so hard to make it and we've all seen
them you know right there dreams no time
to go back back okay um but yeah and we
all are in a sentient and it does sound
daunting and like how's anybody gonna
rise above right this whole level right
here Jack I wanted to go back to
something just real quickly that you
said about the the spiritual death that
you were feeling and and anybody who's
ever gone without money knows that
sometimes you most certainly have to
take some job to pay the bills and that
it can't all be about some artistic
vision so when you do have a project and
you don't have to name which one but
when you do have a project that you're
not your heart's not in it how do you
keep going how does the inertia of that
you know what this is not my thing not
beat you down and you can still kind of
keep showing up every day well it's the
okay but it's not a user's but i should
say go you know i should be clear that
it's not a lot of money but it's money
shed it and you're being paid to do you
know if you studied film in school or if
you just learned it however you learned
that you're being paid to do something
you know that you love to do even if
it's not the project that is going to
you know you know it'd be a renaissance
or something in your mon person but it's
it's it's it's still you're being paid
to do the work and so there's a joy in
filmmaking it so there's a joy in
creating images for me and putting shots
together and just working you know with
the clay or whatever you want to call it
that is and if you're getting paid for
it even if it's not a ton of money is I
think reward enough and so I think the
inspiration comes from that fact not
even the money first but the idea that
that you know that you're working you
get to work you get to work I mean I've
always looked at filmmaking as being one
of those things plenty of metaphors for
it but it's like if you're a pain if
you're if you're a singular artist if
you're if you're a poet you know you
have an inspiration you write it down if
you're a painter if you're lucky enough
to have enough money for a canvas you
open your paint box and you paint and
get app there's a one-to-one
relationship between this is what I feel
I'm a songwriter pick up my guitar play
I can middle a night I got this
inspiration if you're a filmmaker and
you get an inspiration it's like unless
you are self financed which very few of
us are it's like somebody's locked up
your box of paints and you spend a
zillion years however long is going to
take getting the frickin key to unlock
the goddamn paint box so you can paint
so when they finally unlock it even if
it's not you know the ideal project it's
still like thank you you know God for
thank you I finally get to paint you
know and so that's the you know I am NOT
the first one to say that but what Orson
Welles had said this thing late in his
career which was filmmaking is ninety
percent hustling and ten percent filming
and then he said that's no way to spend
a life which was a very kind of bitter
way of looking at cuz yet you think
Orson Welles what
and you know people would have been
falling down to give him projects and he
made very few movies but spends all his
time hustlin you know arsenal so we're
all hustlers but I don't think very few
of us enjoy that you're hustling out of
necessity so that you'll somebody will
open the paintbox you get to do what you
want to do so when you know even if it's
not the ideal project it's still film
you know which is you know an honor to
work you know it's an honor to be making
a film whatever it is yeah so Jack that
the trailer to mega shark vs giant
octopus had over a million hits on
mtv.com another million hits on YouTube
it was featured on the front page of
yahoo it's reached a mass audience yeah
and yet at the same time there's the
other side of it we're on rotten
tomatoes that had a 16-percent rating um
very good yeah it's not bad no I mean at
a 2.7 rating on IMDb I mean were you
able to do all you wanted to do with the
film and any do you know I mean who does
the success no well look this is a real
to me the fact that some guy who kills
people followed mega shark was I think
if you only looked at those two movies
that that was a very big learning
experience personal learning experience
for me because I made mega shark vs
giant octopus look whatever I make
whatever I make again because it's so
rare that you get to make a movie any
movie I break my back trying to make it
but the but the parameters of mega shark
vs giant octopus who was producing it
how they make movies the elements I was
handed the time I was handed and it was
only I knew it was only ever going to be
stupid little piece of you know
that's all I knew it was going to be
that I a by job was to make it to
genuinely polish the turd like to make
something my my goal with that thing was
that at least what I want people to walk
away with from that movie is that they
would know that I know that it's
ridiculous like I want them to know that
I know this is this is a shitty little
movie but at least it's kind of stupid
and fun and you can get high and watch
or whatever it you know III didn't it
wasn't you know is the least thing in my
filmography the irony is that the movies
that I had done previously which I
considered you know real representations
of my work as a fill
maker didn't make it the same kind of
dentist this stupid little thing now I
know people some people really like it I
know they like it because they get the
camp aspect which is the only thing I
was able to put over but in terms of
being able to finesse the movie the way
I would do it typically like i did with
i mean let me put this way someone who
kills people mega shark vs giant octopus
virtually the same budget in the same
budget range one was what some guy who
kills people was the exact opposite in
terms of being able to really control
what the movie was going to be mega
shark vs giant octopus was like shooting
something and then like throwing it into
a blender and hoping you know the way
that process worked it's a miracle that
it's even coherent that thing you know
there are things in that movie where
they would actually in order to get me
to running time I've said this before
this is the degree of insanity you know
like a writer willful labor over whether
there should be an and or an or like all
nights for being a hand or right editing
is like that you know you decide Jesus
two frames less or more makes the
difference in this case mega shark vs
giant octopus the producers needed the
movie to be a certain length of time
they needed to be I think the movie came
in at 93 minutes they needed to be like
97 minutes for some release and Asia or
something so they went in and they added
pauses like it's almost like double
spacing a script they just went in and
added pauses like you know instead of
like adding shots of maybe the mega
shark and the I China octopus
killing each other some more with people
that's goddamn name of the movie is what
an added pauses so they made every scene
which was already compromised even worse
at last my wife says it turned a bad
scene into a scene out of a porno movie
you know what I mean it would be like
you know typically like this is the
examples okay look there's the octopus
and typically it's like look dezzy aquos
you cut right and it'd be like look
there's the octopus one one thousand two
and three or that and and and the
reaction from the from the producer it
would be like you know what it's 97
minutes we did our juggle so that the
opposite of working with ryan on this
where we really were like every moment
that we could make better we could is
the and that's what that's what's
rewarding
and so the irony that mega shark vs
giant octopus has the attention that
this shows me the topsy-turvy dumb of
the business like it's the work it's
this least thing I've ever made and yet
it's the thing that everybody knows so
like I can't put that you can't can't
you know remedy that and I'm brain you
know it's just it's sort of like okay
listen you just entered bizarro world
and that's what it is and too bad you
know eat it that's the way it works you
know that it'll happen that way so I'm
just want to point out the last thing
you know it's like I wanted Mega Shark I
wanted people to know that I was goofin
on Ed Wood that I wasn't ed wood and
thank God we made some guy who kills
people cuz at least people i know i can
say look see I'm not that guy even if
you thought i was at wood i'm not
actually that boy hopefully people will
say and we removed all pauses from some
guy who kill people which is why it's 12
minutes long so it was a learning
experience i'm loving thank thank you
for that jack
we are in studio with filmmakers Jack
Perez and Ryan Levin of some guy who
kills people which is currently
screening in film festivals all around
the world please visit the website at
some guy who kills people calm so Ryan I
with all of years of trying to raise
money for some guy who kills people and
I believe in the process of which you
attach John Landis to the film only to
lose him right before you're about to
secure financing current so you lose
Landis and as the director and with the
financing so why didn't you just quit at
this point um there were about two weeks
where I did it was it was it had been
such a long process up to that point to
get the financing that to have it sort
of dangling in front of us and then
snatched away at the last second that
was kind of the the final blow and I in
it it took me a couple weeks to just
kind of step away and process process at
all and and and decide what to do it was
this just a project that just wasn't
meant to happen do I just kill it here
and move on and initially my reactor my
yeah my initial reaction was it's dead
but you know it um you know we're trying
to try to do is to the worst trying to
raise money at the worst possible time
economically and indie film you're not
going to convince an anybody that indie
film is the way to make money so but at
the end of the two weeks I guess I just
sort of got some sort of resurgence and
said well let's just find out what the
minimum amount of money we can make this
movie for is let's let's hire somebody
entire really you know great line
producer to go through it and give us a
budget of what's the minimum amount of
money we can make this movie for and
just forget name actors forget
you know me you know big big name
directors and having tons of extra time
and those just you know shoestring what
can we do this for and it's still a lot
of money not relative to other films but
you know just absolutely it's a lot of
money so but I just I just went out sort
of hat in hand to friends and relatives
and just kind of cobbled it together
over over a few months and and then and
then everything just kind of took off
from there I mean if as soon as we have
the money that we needed plus what we
thought was a little bit more as a
buffer we you know everything just
quickly took off in terms of terms of
casting in terms of hiring jag as a
director in terms of getting the crew
together and then it just became one big
blur of all right let's listen I guess
we're making his movie so I mean there
were so many ups and downs I'm always
sort of going back and thinking okay
well even now as you know we're in the
middle of promoting the film is this the
hardest part trying to sell the film was
writing the film the hardest part was
making the film the hardest part was
editing the film the hardest part was
raising the money that I don't know the
answer they're all extremely difficult
um and yeah i mean i don't know
everybody said okay you've made your
movie you know now comes the hard part
and i would always late yeah well
whatever like it's got to be easier than
what I've been through but yes selling
its no no piece of cake either but yeah
it was just a matter of like needing a
little bit of time to go okay where do I
stand on this needing a couple weeks off
and then saying alright let's just give
it another shot
I'm wondering what that component is
because Jack you talked about it to that
you have to really love this or else
you're just gonna it's survival of the
fittest and so you have those two weeks
where you're like eating Cheetos in
front of the TV and feeling sorry for
yourself and then where's that sort of
rocky moment words that resurgence come
from because so many people would give
up and then beat themselves up for it so
you say there's been a ton of ups and
downs where do you go when that down
hits how do you bring yourself up um I
think part of it is uh it's it's part of
its stubbornness part of its a
competitive drive part of its ambition
maybe nine you know maybe all those
together account for one percent the
other ninety-nine percent is is fear
failure and just saying I failed to make
this happen I'd set out for a goal and I
failed to achieve it that can't happen
so let's make the movie somehow and plus
I still I you know the script I I'd
spent so much time on the script and
getting the script to a place that I was
you know I mean I I love the script when
it was a piece of crap like in the early
drafts and I only came to love it more
as i would get good feedback from people
and it started to take on more you know
resemble more of its current shape and
that to me was like I I can't yes most
most scripts end up not being shot and I
could have just said all right this will
fall into that category you know and you
can fill a landfill with those scripts I
just didn't I didn't I just kind of
refused to let this be one of those
because I wanted to see it may I just
wanted to see it may like I was tired of
seeing it on my computer screen I wanted
to see the film gets shot and I wanted
to see what its stupid as it sounds I
wanted to see what played out in my head
become a reality
somehow someway with some actors under
somebody's direction you know let's talk
let's talk about the script and let's
talk about one of the highlights here
Ryan you know what was going through
your mind you know when you did get into
the hands of John Candice he reads it
and then it sits the next day yeah he
says all right i want to have lunch with
you yeah what was that like for you
going to head experience that was
completely surreal especially with
everything that had led up to it which
was having you know I mean we had
attacked initially we had tried to go
about raising the money by attaching
name actors and we got some quote
unquote name actors to say they'd be
willing to do it but they weren't of the
quality or caliber not quality acting
wise but just they didn't they weren't
on the list of people that guarantee you
funding or financing so by the time we
got back to them and said you know we
still don't have anything they were like
either who are you I remember attaching
my name to your project or okay well
good luck with it I'm going on to my
other project and then when we first you
know decided to switch tax and say all
right let's try going with the director
it was just completely surreal to say
all right first choice John Landis send
it to him next day let's have lunch next
day sitting with John land is having
lunch and you know I mean he's made some
of my favorite movies if I had to make a
top 10 list I can i would say at least
four of them would would be Landis films
and yeah it was just a completely
surreal experience and and then getting
the chance to to work with him on the
script for a few days over the next
couple we
and getting his his his thoughts his
notes and being able to like it was just
so cool to get notes from him and then
go home and saying I'm gonna rewrite
this based on John Landis's notes like
it was just as opposed to like I'm
getting this I'm I'm rewriting this
based off my dad's notes it was it was
just invigorating so I'd go back to him
and be like so so here you go here did
you like it if you like it you like it's
a better and you yeah much better it's
much better oh my god is much better
this is amazing and then you know so we
did that a few times and it was it was
exhilarating and and then crushing when
he backed out and I was like oh yeah
this feeling okay good yeah I remember
this one but I mean he you know
eventually we ended up I I ended up
asking him hey look to be honest like
you helped me with the script a and be
like having your name attached can help
us with this movie would you be willing
to put your name on his executive
producer and has a smart businessman he
said sure for a cut of the profits and I
said sure there's not committee process
you know um yeah sure yeah you you want
97 points you got him no but he doesn't
have a 97 points I hope not um Jeff with
my lawyer um but he he agreed to do it
and it's funny because we he was
shooting in berk inherit in the UK and
we sent him a rough draft of the cut to
get notes on and he called me and he
left me this message which i still have
which is basically like I watched the
cut he's like I cannot believe how good
this movie is like to be honest I
expected when you told me like what
budget you were now making this movie at
and you know no offense to Jack like
with
director that I've never heard of but
you know like I expected this to be
awful he's like you have a damn good
picture here and he gave us a ton of
notes which we incorporated which made
it that much better and ever since then
you know he's been extremely supportive
of the film and in terms of the film
festivals in terms of just you know
talking it up whatever he can so yeah I
mean he continues to be an asset a
supporter maybe one day he and I'll work
together in some capacity but he's a
he's a genuinely great guy who I feel
like there's a side of him that really
likes being kind of playing that mentor
role and helping young filmmakers or
screenwriters sort of either get better
or get their picture made or whatever it
is um but I think that interest is
question yeah I mean solutely your short
answer is it was surreal yeah and then
and then I just gave you the login thank
you and then Jack we have a quote that
we found from you that we'd like to talk
about you say if you make a slip and
casting it'll haunt you forever so cast
carefully the look of an actor is way
less important than what's behind their
eyes yeah I still believe that I i think
that people sometimes get caught up in
the idea that they visualize the the
character in their mind physically and
when you go into auditions you're
looking for that I sort of match and I
think that if you'd if you have a choice
between two actors one who doesn't even
maybe he's not even the same ethnicity
and that came up recently a film student
of mine asked me you know I've got this
character found this great actor but
she's the mom I like for the movie is
white and the little girl is is East
Indian but I never imagined what do i do
I said well look if these are really the
two best actors that you have then you
find a way to you make an adjustment
even the script or whatever because the
acting the the the emotional quality of
an actor
how truthful they are how much they they
really are able to communicate that
character is way more important than any
physicality nobody you know physical
look like even in the case of some guy
kills people Lucy Davis from the office
the original BBC office and Shaun of the
Dead came in to read for the part Kevin
Corrigan's love interest which I was
like castor you know like this she came
in to audition great you know she's I
was a fan but you know she's Britt and
then and I can't tell you how many
people leave it on Xena Warrior Princess
and we you know they would like have all
these Kiwi actors speak with American
accents because they were afraid of the
accent I was like Lucy's at natural
accent was charming and part of her
personality I didn't want her to have to
do an American accent and why and I
talked about it and thankfully Ryan was
like yeah just write us a line where we
explained she's in the small town
because she followed some guy that's
great you know and that's who she isn't
boom it's over and now you got the best
actor in there and that was really the
case with some guy who kills people
which is rare which is that we just got
having to get the best actors for these
parts this is completely locked out you
know but don't ever cast for you know
cast for somebody that really triggers
that thing inside of you that goes yeah
that guys are real this is a real person
and forget the physicality that's what
comes across you know you know Jackie
you know you kind of touched on it
already you know that that you had a
sort of fight to direct this movie how
important was this movie overall to you
and what do you think you did to earn
the job to earn this directing job uh I
just you know I what I've just really
quickly what i did was i just i knew i
needed to make the movie otherwise i was
going to die you know like i was going
to die and i was never gonna want to
make another movie I was like at that
point where I was just like I hate it
was hating the whole experience of it I
was very sad and so I knew I needed the
movie to to get back you know and so I
just went to Ryan and told him you know
i just opened my heart and said this is
i believe in this thing i know what this
movie is and i want to serve this script
and i wasn't interested in changing the
script or anything I just told them I
would be the guy I get you I get this I
want to realize this here are some quick
story boards that I had some ideas I
sketched them out really think the ideas
came very quickly showed it to them so
did to him and I was just honest that I
I could do this and I didn't have to
bullsh
because I knew it is i clicked with the
material and that was a lucky break
unfortunately Ryan you know took a
chance and said okay you know I know you
made this stupid mega shark movie but
for some reason you seem to like this so
and can do it I said believe and that's
that's how I got it this earnest be our
earnest is the best hustle I guess
unfortunately i went back and watch
other films of yours thank you thank you
i think i cry i think i made him i said
please watch so anything up yet so just
real quick as we wrap up here how do you
handle the unknown of being in this
business business in between jobs how do
you have that faith that another one's
going to come up and that's going to be
one that's going to be something you
want to do so you don't go through that
spiritual death and that sort of
depression or whatever it is how do you
keep that momentum going um well you do
go through the depression I'm just
accepted yeah so that's not one word
comes out yeah exactly or something more
powerful but legal you know I I guess it
goes back to something jack said which
is as a writer what i can do is i can
just keep writing and if i had to sort
of rely like an actor has to rely on
somebody granting them apart that would
be more soul-crushing than sort of the i
mean that unknown would be more
soul-crushing then I don't have a job I
need a job let's wait for the phone to
ring and as hard as it is to just you
know I find writing extremely difficult
i'm a very slow writer right things
don't just pop into my head you know as
fleshed out as some other people with
i'm quite jealous or you know you can
crank things out much faster i mean so
it takes me a lot of time but at the
same time I know that my way out of this
hole or my way my way to answer the
question of will I get another job I can
increase the chances by sitting down and
writing something whether it's weather
a TV pilot or a screenplay or even a
short whatever whatever I happen to be
inspired to write at that particular
moment that gives me some sense of
control like you know I have i can write
something i can get it to people that
will get it out there and you know
chances are it won't sell or land me a
job but the next one will or the next
one will and yeah it's just you know go
back to just the this the saying of like
you know if you're a writer you have to
write and that's to me it's somewhat of
an obsession like I'm obsessed by imma
I'm obsessed with writing so I I have to
be doing it so what I'm not when I'm not
employed I'm just writing and that's
somehow in some way moving me closer to
the next job and as soon as I get that
next job then my question becomes okay
well it's even while I'm having that
jobs and what was the next job looks
like no no try to stay in the present
and that's a whole other challenge but
yeah I mean you go the ups and downs are
inevitable the rejections inevitable but
the least as a writer you can do
something about it which is just write
anything to know I think that's really
good i think that's you know and and
also watching you know watching stuff
that inspires you watching really good
movies you know not just watching the
crap i mean we're in a pretty low ebb
here it's that sort of the nadir of
cinema mean this stuff but there's a lot
of the bottom quota new releases are not
the things that are really going to
inspire you to go up so what I do is I
go back to a lot of old movies I just
watch the movies that inspired me i look
for things that are that are complex not
in an art you're not in an intellectual
way but just that have a lot going on in
terms of the filmmaking terms of the
choices in terms of how much risk in
terms of what can really be done look at
those movies that
really made you want to be a filmmaker
and it reminds you yeah this there is
art here and there is poetry here even
in any genre you know and I want and
remind you I want to be a part of that
so I think watch good stuff and you'll
be reminded why you got into it in the
first place we've been speaking with
director Jack Perez and screenwriter
Ryan Levin of the horror comedy some guy
who kills people great film go out and
watch it awesome yeah awesome for more
on jacket Ryan please visit some guy who
kills people calm you can find them on
facebook / some guy who kills people on
twitter some guy who kills as well as
IMDB thank you jack and ryan yeah for
being here with the same thank you so
much for having in a pleasure yeah
really a lot of fun and thank you for
joining us on yet another edition of
film courage we look forward to being
here with you next sunday at noon on la
talk radio com and we'll be joined by
documentary filmmaker Doug block for
more on Doug block please visit his
amazing site duh excuse me d hyphen word
com which is a worldwide community site
for documentary filmmakers and also doug
block weddings com yeah and before we
leave big shout out to Ronan thank you
and thank you for keeping us on pace we
know we ran a little long but we would
be lost without you running and until
next Sunday have a great week
you